[Music]
so a recent set of controversies has to
do with the funding by the federal
government about research that mixes
human and animal genetic material
sometimes called chimeras but there was
actually a broad or group of us and
again the method is to think about a
large number of cases it's helpful to
think about very different cases so to
use some real cases imagine you mixed
human brain cells or human brain stem
cells in the embryonic stage into a
mouse to create a mouse with a humanized
brain now it wouldn't be a human brain
that's exactly the same it's much
smaller for example but has humanized
elements another example is imagining
took a gorilla treated the gril exactly
as it is but were able to generate a
human looking face right so a gorilla
with a human face how would we think
about that entity third example
humanized and immune system took a mouse
and we do this we have these at Harvard
for example and created an immune system
in order to test drugs think about HIV
for example that was humanized so not
the brain but just the immune system was
very human-like and last example is
actually valve replacements heart valve
replacements so Jesse Helms the senator
had a pig valve replacement years ago
right so there's a piece of an animal in
him right so these are four examples of
different kinds of mixing and the
question is which are okay which are not
okay why can we generate some principles
so what might be wrong with mixing human
and animal parts so one thing they might
be wrong is that we think it will
confuse the boundaries between humans
and animals right them right now we have
a pretty clear distinction while many
people love their dogs and their cats
like members of the family they are able
to say this is not a member of my family
this is not a member that has the same
rights as my family member in a world
where we had much more of a continuum
between animals and human beings those
distinctions would become difficult
now just because they become difficult
doesn't mean that that's wrong right we
just post Russ a new problem and maybe
it would illustrate a problem we should
be thinking about altogether so I'm not
particularly sympathetic to that
argument different argument though is to
say
human beings are particulars of
capacities and there's a dignity to
being human being and if we were to mix
enough animal material into a human
being the thing that we would have would
not be something new but would be a
human being that could not flourish as a
human being being undignified human
being a kind of entity that is one that
really is unable to really experience
what it is to be human
now again you might push on this and say
well yes that's true they would not be a
human being and they would not be that
so they have all the capacities of the
human beings I think imagine having some
of the capacities of human being would
being stuck in a rack body for example
sure there'd be ways in which you would
not flourish as a human being but why
not think of you as flourishing as a new
kind of entity right and in particular
you might actually think that might be
an obligation to create some kinds of
chimeras so if for example we think of a
big bird from Sesame Street sounds like
a silly example but it's a good one
right big bird talks Big Bird has
friends big bird goes to school been in
school a long time was estimated Street
I guess but he seems to have a pretty
good life right imagine we could take
regular birds and turn them into big
birds by doing something to them right
when we think of that as improving a
little birds life but we think about
that as hurting a human beings life
right through this mixture hard
questions right but at least it might be
possible that we think we're doing
animals a favor by doing this and other
answers might say it depends a lot on
the specifics of the case right there
are changes we could make to human
beings by mixing an animal DNA that
might make them better and there are
changes we could make to human beings
and make them worse and worse from moral
perspective so for example I've it
turned out that there was to use an
example in the literature we could give
human beings night vision so they could
see at night like some animals through
mixing in a little animal DNA you might
think that would be great right we could
do more search and rescue we'd be better
drivers there'd be less fatalities on
the other hand if the result was to
produce human beings that had much
stronger aggression or violence or claws
or something like that you might think
that's worse because we're gonna do more
harm and that would suggest the answer
about whether we ought to have chimeras
are not on what
fine can only be answered in a
particular istic way about thinking
about a particular case I will say and
this is kind of referencing some work by
my friend Hank really at Stanford that
there are particular kinds of changes
which from a sociological perspective
seem to bother us more and he describes
them as kind of brains balls and faces
so brains turns out we're very disturbed
by the idea of human brains or humanized
brains in animals much more disturbed by
the humanized brain mice than we are by
the humanized immune system mice for
example the other is balls we tend to be
very nervous when we think about the
idea and this is kind of crazy and out
there imagine you could create an animal
that had the ability to reproduce it's
it's gonads its reproductive system was
human so that you'd have animals mating
and producing human beings and animals
right that's the kind of thing I think
disturbs a lot of people is an idea and
the last is face is the idea of having
animals with human faces for example I
think just disturbs a lot of people even
though you might say a face is a face
but it's a marker of human being isn't
the way we relate to each other and I
think there was just a strong
sociological pushback against that
[Music]